clowns
some love them
lots hate them
but in the uk it's a serious business
oh sorry just snipe my nose off
it's a responsibility
it is for fun as well to do of course
that's debbie my name is debbie and i'm
the clown egg artist she's in charge of
the clown egg registry a collection of
every single clown's face in all of the
united kingdom
tradition of the painting of the eggs
was started first of all as a hobby by
stan bolt it then became a way of
recording and copywriting clown's face
because every clown's face is different
various different artists
then became the egg artists and i took
over six years ago
debbie's job is to paint onto an egg the
unique makeup of each clown it's nice to
have a physical object that looks like
that character
it's so totally different to having a
photograph the clown egg registry is a
collection of dozens of eggs that serves
as an official list of each individual
clown's personality and look
when the order comes through for an egg
the clown will send his application form
along with some samples of material and
send photographs of himself different
angles
i start by sketching the portrait onto
the egg and then gradually add color
with the paint so sometimes it's actual
hair that i would like wool that i will
make into hair to put on so it depends
on the character but they're all there
to make you laugh
can you pose again please
it's a responsibility because it is very
important to carry on that tradition
[Music]
you